I think he I think he clarified it and I
do have to say this we yesterday had a
tremendous day in Texas we opened a
Louis Vuitton plant one of the great
brands of the world and they opened it
right in the heart of Texas Lone Star
State and then we went over to Dallas
and had an event like few people have
ever seen we have a packed arena with
thousands and thousands of people
outside it was an incredible evening got
back very very late I did actually get
to hear about ambassador Kent this is
the witch hunt you know their their
crooked ship is coming after the
Republican Party he's coming after the
Republican Party as hard as he can
considering he's really he's been
compromised very sadly and badly because
of the fact as you know I think as the
press knows he made a statement and he
made a virtual speech about what I said
and then it turned out that I didn't say
any of it because he fraudulently made
this statement to Congress I thought
what he did was one of the worst things
I understand he has immunity but he
doesn't have immunity when he puts it on
his Twitter which he did and he doesn't
have immunity or he speaks to press
which he did